it's up on the screen what happens here
you can have a good time
Jack John
Jon Bernthal he plays plunger Johnny
what's up what are you doing here you're
not this is like you're not even
scheduled to be here there's like what
are you doing here the clip let's play
yeah I was cool like everybody cheers
drink like a hotter school okay well I'm
trying to do the show me the clip that
you just showed just see that again
does anybody want to see the trailer
from the beginning
thank you John thank you sir what's up
San Diego and can we just give it up
real quick for the professor the man
that makes it all happen mr. Jeff Loeb
real quick we obviously haven't a chance
to talk in front of this group so either
just I I know that you stopped by
because I know you're making a movie
right now which accounts for all this
stuff that's going on with you ah so we
appreciate you coming by tell me and
tell them what was it like when you you
found out that you were going to play
Frank Castle on daredevil season two um
look you know you know I've said it
before I know how much he means to you
guys and I take that with me every day
and and I know how much this character
matters I know how much he means to
members of the military to law
enforcement and I take it as an enormous
responsibility and an enormous honor and
I'm eternally grateful
so you play the part you can't walk down
the street anymore I mean people knew
you Shane before but now on something
else I don't know what that is but but
now your Frank Castle tell me at how is
your life changed in in that way or is
that the reason why you grew the beard
and your hair is long and oh yeah yeah
he's in a suit okay look I I think that
you know the Marvel fans and comic book
fans the greatest fans in the world and
you know again it's uh I can't tell you
how how grateful I am for the the
feedback but you know Frank is he's in
my he's in my bones now and he's with me
so I think if anything it just makes me
you know love my family harder squeeze
my kids harder and I think of anything
I've just been grateful for every day
and again just enormous ly enormous ly
grateful for this opportunity and and
while everybody here may not believe us
that the truth is that we had we were
hopeful that when we started daredevil
that that we would be able to make a
very special phone call to you which was
to tell you that we are now going to go
into production on a Punisher series on
Netflix
what was that day like when you found
out you now we're going to have your own
show time to get going you know
get it right work work work work and you
know yeah it's a safe answer man main
floor I'm ready you know it's hot all
right I really John seriously just came
by to say hello
I just can everyone please thank him for
coming by
hey y'all Luke Cage looks very very good
y'all this is gonna be that I mean I am
very very excited I hope y'all are
excited as I am they're back there and
oh man oh man Luke Cage
you
you